♪♪
>>> WE HAVE BEEN TALKING A LOT
ABOUT THE AIRLINE CHAOS.
AND ESPECIALLY THE STORMS THAT
HAVE CRIPPLED SO MANY
OPERATIONS.
BUT THE STORY IS NOT ABOUT
SOUTHWEST AIRLINES.
IT'S A DIFFERENT AIRLINES BUT
SIGNIFICANT CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE
OF THE STORM.
A MAN IN ALASKA WAS WAITING FOR
A HEART TRANSPLANT AFTER ONLY
HAVING BEEN ON THE LIST FOR A
FEW WEEKS, PATRICK HOLLAND GOT A
CALL THAT A DONOR MATCH HAD BEEN
FOUND AND HE WAS GETTING A
HEALTHY HEART.
BUT THINGS TURNED WHEN THE
FLIGHT HE WAS ON COULDN'T MAKE
IT FROM ALASKA TO SEATTLE
BECAUSE OF THE STORM.
HIS WIFE WRITING IN PART ON
FACEBOOK QUOTE THE PAST 25
HOURS, THE MOST TRAUMATIC,
DIFFICULT HOURS OF PATRICK'S
LIFE.
NUMEROUS TIMES HIS HOPES AND
DREAMS WERE LIFTED AND THEN LEFT
TO TUMBLE DOWN TO NIGHTMAISH
PROPORTIONS.
HIS CANCELED FLIGHT MEANT LOSING
A CHANCE FOR THAT HEART
TRANSPLANT.
WHAT AIRLINE WAS THIS?
>> IT WAS ALASKA AIRLINE.
>> OKAY.
AND IT'S BECAUSE OF THE STORM,
CORRECT?
>> YES.
BECAUSE OF THE STORM.
ALASKA AIRLINE, THEY -- THEY
JUMPED THROUGH HOOPS TO GET ME
THERE.
>> I'M SO GLAD -- I'M SO SORRY
IT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE.
WE HEARD WHAT YOUR WIFE WROTE,
WHAT IT HAS BEEN LIKE FOR YOU,
BECAUSE YOU COULDN'T GET TO
SEATTLE TO GET THE TRANSPLANT.
>> IT WAS -- IT WAS TERRIFYING
NEWS TO HEAR THAT I WAS GOING TO
GET A TRANSPLANT, TO BE HONEST
WITH YOU, I WAS TERRIFIED.
AND THEN I WAS EXCITED.
SO WE CAUGHT THE FIRST FLIGHT
OUT.
WE GOT TO THE AIRPORT AND IT WAS
PACKED.
WHICH IS UNUSUAL.
IT WAS PACKED BECAUSE FLIGHTS
WERE BEING CANCELED AND I DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT UNTIL I WENT TO THE
KIOSK AND MY FLIGHT WAS
CANCELED.
AND AFTER WAITING IN LINE FOR AN
HOUR PANICKING, REALIZING MY
FLIGHT WAS LEAVING IN HALF AN
HOUR, I WAVED DOWN A WOMAN THAT
WORKED FOR ALASKA AIRLINES AND I
TOLD HER THE SITUATION, TOLD HER
I'M A HEART TRANSPLANT, THIS IS
CRUCIAL.
SHE WAVED ME TO THE FRONT OF THE
LINE AND SHE SAID, YEAH, YOUR
FLIGHT HAS BEEN CANCELED AND
THEN MY HEART SANK.
SHE SAID, I WILL GET YOU ON A
PLANE, AND SHE DID.
SHE GOT ME ON A PLANE.
AND FROM THERE, WE WERE DIVERTED
ABOUT HALFWAY THROUGH, I DIDN'T
KNOW THAT BECAUSE THEY HAD
ANNOUNCED IT BUT I GUESS DURING
MY EXCITEMENT OF GETTING A HEART
WAS -- WAS OVERWHELMING.
>> YEAH.
>> BUT WE -- WE WERE IN FLIGHT
FOR ABOUT FOUR HOURS AND I HEARD
THE PILOT SAY THAT, HEY, WELCOME
TO ANCHORAGE.
AND I THOUGHT HE MUST BE REALLY
TIRED BECAUSE WE'VE BEEN IN THE
AIR FOR ABOUT FOUR HOURS AND IT
DOESN'T TAKE FOUR HOURS TO GET
TO ANCHORAGE.
AND A LADY OVERHEARD ME TELL MY
BROTHER THAT, SHE LOOKED OVER
AND SAID MY PHONE SAYS
ANCHORAGE.
AND I STARTED TO PANIC AND MY
PHONE SAID ANCHORAGE AND MY
WORST FEARS WERE OVERWHELMING
ME.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU HEAR THAT,
YOU'RE LIKE, THERE'S SOMEBODY
DONATING A HEART AND THEY
DON'T -- I DON'T IMAGINE THEY
CAN WAIT THAT LONG BECAUSE THE
LONGER IT WAITS THE LONGER THE
TISSUE DECOMPOSES.
SO SHE SAID DON'T WORRY.
SHE SAID THIS HEART IS FOR YOU,
WE'RE GOING TO WAIT AND CATCH
THE NEXT FLIGHT IMMEDIATELY.
GREAT, I WAS LIFTED AGAIN.
THIS IS GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND WE GOT ANOTHER FLIGHT
SCHEDULED FOR LIKE 45 MINUTES
LATER.
THERE WAS A GENTLEMEN, ROY,
THERE WHO JUST ACCOMMODATED
LIKE -- I WAS IMPRESSED, I WAS
AMAZED.
HE CHECKED ON ME EVERY TEN
MINUTES.
AND HE WALKED BACK WITH VERY BAD
NEWS THAT THE FLIGHT WAS
CANCELED AGAIN.
SO THEN I CALLED THE HEART
TRANSPLANT COORDINATOR AND SHE
EXPLAINED TO ME, LET'S NOT GIVE
UP.
LET'S KEEP TRYING.
BUT I REALIZED IN ANCHORAGE AT
THE TIME THERE WAS ALSO A STORM
GOING ON.
IT WAS CRAZY TO WATCH IT FROM
OUT THE WINDOW.
AND THEN THE SECOND FLIGHT GOT
CANCELED AND THEN THE THIRD
FLIGHT GOT CANCELED.
AT THIS POINT I KNEW.
I TOLD MY BROTHER, I SAID, THE
NEXT PHONE CALL IS NOT GOING TO
BE GOOD.
JUST AS I WAS CALLING HER, SHE
WAS CALLING ME BACK TO TELL ME
THEY WERE GOING TO GIVE THE
HEART TO SOMEBODY ELSE.
>> I CANNOT -- I CAN'T IMAGINE
GETTING THAT PHONE CALL.
I MEAN, YOU'RE ONLY 56 YEARS
OLD.
YOU LOOK YOUNGER.
YOU'RE ONLY 56.
AND YOU HAVE A 3-YEAR-OLD.
I THINK WE HAVE SOME --
>> I DO.
>> IMAGES WE CAN SHOW OF YOU AND
YOUR CHILD AND FAMILY TO YOUR
VIEWERS.
THIS IS WHAT THE HEART MEANS TO
YOU.
>> YES.
>> THIS IS ABOUT BEING ABLE TO
RUN AROUND AFTER YOUR
3-YEAR-OLD.
>> IT'S TOUGH TO -- TO HAVE A
BODY THAT WANTS TO RUN BUT NOT
TO HAVE A HEART THAT WILL LET
YOU.
SO IT'S -- IT TAKES AWAY A LOT.
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT, ON THE SAME
SIDE, I BELIEVED THAT SOMEBODY
ELSE WAS GOING TO GET A MIRACLE
GIFT.
>> YEAH.
>> SO WE JUST PRAYED FOR THEM.
SO SOMEWHERE, SOMEBODY ELSE WAS
GOING TO -- YEAH.
SO YOU GOT TO LOOK AT THE BRIGHT
SIDE OF THINGS.
ON THE BRIGHT SIDE I GOT TO GO
BACK HOME TO MY FAMILY AND HAVE
A GOOD CHRISTMAS WITH THEM
AGAIN.
THERE IS A BIG PART OF ME THAT
FEELS LIKE I LET THEM DOWN BY
NOT BEING IN SEATTLE.
SO I -- I BLAME MYSELF FOR THAT
PART.
>>
ONCE I HEARD I WAS ACTIVE, I
COULD HAVE IMMEDIATELY MADE
PLANS TO BE THERE.
I WAS NEAR THE BOTTOM OF THE
LIST, NUMBER SIX, SO I HAD NO
CLUE.
AND WE -- FROM ALL OF THE
STORIES THAT WE WATCHED, IT
TAKES MONTHS.
AND IT JUST HAPPENED TO BE A
MIRACLE TO BE -- GET AN OFFER
AFTER TWO AND A HALF WEEKS.
AND I JUST FEEL LIKE I SHOULD
HAVE BEEN MORE PROACTIVE IN
BEING THERE.
SO I'LL BE THERE NEXT WEEK IF
THINGS WORK OUT.
>> PLEASE DON'T BLAME YOURSELF.
THIS IS NOT YOUR FAULT.
AND LET'S -- WITH CAN HE END IT
ON SOME GOOD NEWS.
YOU'VE HAD SOME AMAZING PEOPLE
REACH OUT TO YOU FROM SEATTLE
WHERE YOU NEED TO BE AND OFFER
SOME GREAT THINGS FOR YOU.
>> YES.
IT'S BEEN REALLY GREAT.
I'VE HAD PLANNED WITH THREE
DIFFERENT PEOPLE THAT I KNOW
THAT LIVE IN SEATTLE.
ONE WAS MET WITH FOUL PLAY AND
TWO OTHERS JUST FAMILY MEMBERS
MOVED BACK AND IT WAS JUST
WASN'T WORKING OUT.
SO I WAS ACTUALLY LOOKING
THROUGH MY CHURCHES THAT I'M
INVOLVED WITH TO COME UP WITH AN
IDEA.
AND WE WERE WORKING ON SOMETHING
AND THAT IS WHEN I GOT THE CALL.
SO I JUST WISH I COULD HAVE BEEN
THERE.
AND, YOU KNOW, IT IS -- THEY
WORK MIRACLES NOWADAYS AND
SOMEONE GOT A MIRACLE.
THAT IS WHEN I HOPE WAS, THAT
SOMEONE ELSE GOT TO APPRECIATE
THE EXTRA TIME.
>> IT SHOWS WHAT A BIG HEART YOU
HAVE AND WE'RE ALL PRAYING FOR
YOUR NEW HEART WHEN THAT IS TO